.
Véronique Prince la suivi dans
- Le constat était frappant
le mois dernier.
- Je, Audrey Bogemans,
déclare...
- Avec 41 nouveaux élus,opopopos
de la politique.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est dans un restaurant de sa
circonscription qu'on re
la nouvelle députée
d'Iberville : Audrey Bememans.
- Merci.
SYLVIE D'AMOURS, C C C C C C C l
- Moi, j'ai eu la chance
de parler avec Audrey avant
la campagne électorale.
des questions.
"J'ai enenenfants, mon conjoint,
ma famille..." Alors moi,
j'avais comme mandat d'appeler
à ses questions.
- Parce qu'elle manquait de
temps pour prendre toutes ses
recrues par la main, le e e e es
pour leur expliquer la vie
parlementaire.
- Il faut comprendre quel rôle
on joue. Et c'esifififififififis
personnes. Il y en a qui
ne le comprennent jamais.
CLAIRE SAMSON,
ancienne d- - - - - - - - - - -s
comme moi, ça n'a pas travaillé
fort depuis deux ans, ça là.
- L'ex-députée Claire Samson,
pa
son rôle durant le dernier
mandat, croit Sylvie D'Amours.
- La marque, là, c'est dans
ton comté qu'il faut que tu
AUDREY BOGEMANS,
députée, CAQ, Iberville
- Dans n'importe lequel emploi,
je pense qu'il y a des gens
la différence et d'autres qui
peuvent s'asseoir fifififiter
du bateau, finalement, je pense,
pendant qu'il y en a d'autres
- Audrey ne sera jamais
une plante ver
(rires)
- Il y a pas de danger!
- Ce qui la fait moins rire,
c'est dédédédépartir des actions
de son entreprise, une ferme
familiale. Obligation de
- C'est avec mes parents, mon
mememememes soeurs ont été élevs
dans cette entreprise-là.
une valeur sentimentale au-delà
de la valeur monpupupupupuis
c'est un détachement de dire :
je la mets de côté pour être
- Sylvie d'Amours l'a aussi
vécu, comme agricultrice.
Un
maîtrisent, mais dont elle
ne pourront jamais débattre
au Parlement, pour éviter
les conflits d'intérêt.
- Elle a la vie devant elle
comme  D D D D Donc, elle peut
s'ouvrir à d'autres dossiers
qu'elle connaît un peu moins.
- On se voit à l'Assemblée
nationale. s s s s s s s s s s e
prochaine.
- Parfait.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour les aider à apprivoiser
tous ces changements dans
leur vie, l'Assemblée nationale
a appelé du renfAVAVAVAVAVAVAVAe
députée, Québec solidaire
- La première chose qu'on
apprend en devenant député,
savait, mais en fait,e e e e e .
- Comme le dernier mandat a été
marqué par l'anxiété et laésésés
durant la pandémie, plusieursone
sécurité, des élus sortants
ont levé la main pour  n n n n .
Une formation, avec les
familles, qui n'existait pas
auparavant.
- Toc, toc!
- Bonjour!
- André A. Morin fait partie
des dix nouveaux visages
au Partivevevevevevevevevevevev!
- Merci!
Cet ancien procureur a vécu
un baptême de feu avec
lal'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'l'le
Marie-Claude Nichols et
la démission de sa cheffe.
Vous étiez au coeur
Ça commençait raide!
ANDRÉ A. MORIN,
député, PLQ, Acadieçaçaçaçaçaçaé
d'aplomb, mettons! Mais ça,
ça nous a préparé pour les aléas
de la politique, hein? Mais bon!
- Ça vouse?e?e?e?e?e?e?e?e?e?e??
- Du tout, du tout.
- Là, vous vous retrouvez
à devoir suivre une ligne
de parisisisisisisisisisisisisi?
- Oui.
- Oui?
- Oui, ça, il n'y a pas de
savoir qu'il y a une ligne de
parti, mais quand on est entre
nous, on a quand même des bonnes
discussions.usususususususususue
à travers tout ça.
- Absolument.
Ça, c'est bien important.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Merci!
anananananananans a embrassé
ses jumeaux de 8 ans et
sa petite de 3 ans, ce matin.
- Merci!
- ...avant de rejoindre
sa mentore à Québec.
- Sais-tu où t'es assise
aurerererererererererererererer!
- Surprise pour tout le monde.
- Sa nouvelle photo de famille,
c'est celle de son parti
politique, pour les quat
Ici Véronique Prince,
Rad